I was in an abusive marriage and my father
yelled at me that I was going to hell
when I walked out. I'm sorry. I don't
believe in a god that would believe that.
Yeah.
Can I have all of my name?
Yes.
Hi.
One Pizza.
Okay.
You gotta be kidding.
My wife will not have a pizza
unless there's pineapple on it.
You can try anything on paper.
Yeah, why not? I'm going to,
we're going to disagreers
Pete's pizza.
I like you tasted the cheese, the sauce
and the bread. That's it. It's like,
it's like candy.
That's like having candy on a
pizza is that it's like them.
I'm nervous about what's
going to happen today.
I mean I'm,
I'm,
I'm nervous because this is a normal
topic that people can usually talk about,
but in this climate is very
touching me to even say I believe.
I don't believe, you know, it's funny.
I would think that you would feel safer
in the belief category then I feel in
the non belief category, I was raised
in a house very culturally Jewish.
We talked a lot about God and religion
and many different religions of the
world, but, um,
I wasn't raised with any faith with any
religious faith in the house just two
years ago. I hated Christians.
I think I was an atheist,
but I voiced all my doubts and skepticisms
and they gave me their perspective on
it. That kind of opened me up. And
that's why I'm a man of faith today.
I believe.
If I think, if I just choose to believe
that everyone is surely bad or evil,
then that's going to be pretty.
And then you have to decide what
the definition of good it is.
According to Christianity, there
is no one good. No, not one.
But I don't necessarily
believe that if no one's good,
I don't want one with a sin
nature. Yeah. So that's hard.
It's like my definition of good,
it made not align with scripture.
So it's hard because that's why I
hesitated like I want to leave everybody's
good. If antithetical to the
Christian belief is that you're born,
um,
it's sinful.
It's interesting that the three of
you came who are believers in that.
I'm not saying people are innately good.
I'm saying I just learned this other
question as all people are capable of.
Yeah,
no.
Start with Hitler and go from
there are people, you know,
are some people born good and turn bad?
Well,
I think that's what the
definition of good is subjective,
so that's why it's like the each to
each his own for definition and you just
kind of hard.
I don't know what is right or wrong
without the Bible because it's gone,
but it makes the rules really about God.
You have no rules.
You don't. You can't make a decision
on your own whether it's good or bad.
What about handler?
He made the decision.
I thought it was good and he was wrong.
You don't need the Bible to
tell you that. Well, you,
you're born with that God.
Put that in you as
conscious as you believed.
That's not a belief.
It's a fact.
I'm an author of two books where I give
the whole history of the earth from
paleontology, geology, archaeology,
published about four articles on
numerous subjects, including politics,
science meaning Enix dinosaurs
to
my mother.
Yes, I would want people to think
that they have worth and value,
but I mean we are all ants on a big boat.
We are all very important.
The design and those things.
If a man were to design it,
it would cost several million dollars
to make a human if that were possible,
and yet he's,
God has created billions of us.
I believe in people.
I believe we make our own choices.
I don't believe that there is a overriding
being controlling those choices are
controlling our situation.
You are,
and I'm so,
I do not think that inherently just
existing gives you worth and value.
I think that you make choices,
personal choices every single day on
how you live your life and how you treat
people and how you exist
in the world and those,
well, hold on. You just made a
definition about what value is,
but you still don't believe
you're valuable based on
your explanation. I said,
I'm not inherently valuable to my being.
Born does not just based
on your contribution to the
world determines your value.
Don't know.
Please don't.
There are many people who just exist
because of instinct or because do their
lives have value. I don't know if
find value in it. Sure. If they don't,
maybe not who, who am I to judge whether
somebody is life is inherently valuable
on the existence of a higher,
Huh?
I am a woman of faith and belief.
I believe in the supernatural and
higher power and a being that there's no
accident and the way we were created.
Yeah. I think anytime I
have gone through hardship,
I've questioned not just what I believe.
I questioned my life.
I questioned my profession, I
questioned my relationships. So yeah,
and I, I think you know, if you
believe whether it's Islam, Hindu,
I think you have to die. You can't just
jump in there and be like, sign me up.
I agree with everything.
Let's do it.
That would be for you.
But nothing up for everybody that is
a believer of any particular religion.
People don't question anything.
But in your view by standing and saying,
you know,
I don't think there's
any high power you do.
Do you ever face any doubt of thinking?
Maybe there is.
Well, the definition of an atheist
is someone who does not believe.
It's not a declaration per
say that there is no god.
I am an atheist activist.
I'm on the board of atheists United
here in Los Angeles and on the steering
committee for Americans United for
separation of church and state.
No, I've never had a doubt because
I can see design everywhere.
And you are not an atheist. You're an
agnostic. Nope. It's an agnostic. Now,
Leo told me what I am. I am an atheist.
An atheist doesn't. I am an atheist.
Atheist doesn't believe in
the supernatural period.
The atheist and agnostic. No. No. Does
believe the supernatural that does not.
He just doesn't believe in God.
I'm telling you what an atheist is.
No image,
healthiest supernatural.
Do not tell me you don't need
to make anybody right or wrong.
It's just answer the question. Give her
space to talk. Give her space to talk.
Do you believe that this line of
interrogation questioning furthers your,
no,
I'm just giving facts
saved by the bell.
I am feeling frustrated right now.
Yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm feeling frustrated because it's
even amidst the fellow believers,
like the things he says, I'm
just like, Yo, I don't even know.
I don't want what he says to reflect what
my faith is to, you know what I mean?
I think it's sad
that people are so determined to make
other people wrong and I grew up in a
household with it,
conservative Jewish mother and a born
again Christian father and I was in an
abusive marriage and my father yelled at
me that I was to help when I walked out.
I'm sorry.
I don't believe in a God that would
believe that it's not and that is
objectively,
I don't care.
That's crazy.
Exactly. Kind of shuts down conversation.
Exactly what you believe in.
Why White Dome?
Again, we have the power to
choose our response to things,
so I choose not to feel hurt.
I choose not to be misunderstood.
I think there's safety in being heard
and understood. You feel as if the,
whatever it is that you want
to be understood about matters.
I'm getting married in the next
two months that I'm learning
energy and effort to understand someone
who's different. I think, you know,
I think we're kind of as a society
and becoming lazy, so we're like, oh,
you're different. I don't
want to understand. I mean,
people who are just always been that,
oh look,
we all agree.
We all have room for it.
My aspiration on a daily basis
is to be a better person.
We're always learning. I used to
think at some point I would like Oh,
actual allies into, oh, I've made it,
made it into maturity and wisdom.
You know,
when I'm in college, I'll have it
figured out. When I get married,
I'll have it figured out when I have kids.
I have it figured out,
but we're always,
we won't reach perfection until
we get to heaven down here.
As an imperfect world, we can,
our knowledge is imperfect.
Our bodies are in perfect. Our
world is perfect. I mean, I'm,
I'm agreeing with you,
but it's the delivery of it,
right? Let's stay up.
What was the question?
We all believe that we have
room for improve, certainly.
All right. Alyssa, I acknowledge
you for keeping very,
very focused and not getting
ever heated but staying focused.
I appreciate your honesty and the way
you stand up for what you believe.
Nancy,
you have a presence of self.
You have a very still very centered
quality to you that is, um,
very admirable.
Christine,
I acknowledge you for not running
out of the room when you were in a
controversial conversation.
Um,
I acknowledge you for standing your
ground for believing what you believe and
you've got a lot of
fight in you. Uh, Jeremy,
I acknowledge you for being unwaveringly
from and what you believe and not
caring, whether it's controversial
or difficult to say what you believe.
Um,
that is a sign of passion growing up.
I think you're a wonderful guy and your
marriage is going to make it grow even
more.
You just seem like a very comfortable
guy who's willing to learn and grow and
that's a lovely,
lovely quality and something Rissa.
You have this ability to take stock
of yourself and make decisions.
Like when you said, I choose not to be
heard and so I'm not hurt. It's just,
it's an amazing quality in some,
thank you.
Nice to meet you. How are
we invited to the wedding?